So this is what should be done by one who was skilled in goodness and who knows the path of peace.
Let them be able and upright, straightforward and gentle in speech, humble and not conceited, contented and easily satisfied, unburdened with duties and frugal in their ways,
peaceful and calm and wise and skillful, not proud or demanding in nature.
Let them not do the slightest thing that the wise would later reprove.
Wishing, in gladness and in safety, may all beings be at ease.
Whatever living beings there may be, whether they are weak or strong, omitting none, the great or the mighty, medium, short or small, the seen and the unseen, those living near and far away, those born and to be born, may all beings be at ease.
Let none deceive another or despise any being in any state.
let none through anger or ill will wish harm upon another.
Even as a mother protects with her life a child, her only child, so with a boundless heart should one cherish all living beings, radiating kindness over the entire world, spreading upwards to the skies and downwards to the depths.
outwards and unbounded, freed from hatred and ill-will.
Whether standing or walking, seated or lying down, free from drowsiness, one should sustain this recollection.
This is said to be the sublime abiding.
And by not holding to fixed views, the pure-hearted one, having clarity of vision, being freed from all sense desires,
is not born again into this world.